en marge de l'audience mais aussi lors
du rassemblement des partisans d'alexei
navalni à l'annoncé du verdict des
violences ont été une nouvelle fois
observé mais pour le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères le montage des
images effet à charge et le montre que
la riposte des policiers
on ne mentionnant pas les provocations
de plus toujours selon sergueï lavrov
ceux qui donnent des leçons sur les
violences policières aujourd'hui ne sont
pas forcément les plus irréprochables en
la matière l'hystérie dont nous avons
entendu parler liées au procès dans la
sphère en aval n'y dépasse certes les
limites on cache absolument au public le
fait que les lois sur les manifestations
les réunions et toutes sortes d'actions
qui existent en occident sont bien plus
stricte qu'en fédération de russie la
police dans les pays occidentaux a le
droit de réprimer toute forme de
réunions qui n'a pas été autorisé donc
s'ils n'osent pas eu une notification ou
bien si la notification a eu lieu mais
qu'il y à une violation de la procédure
convenue relatives à leur tenue
le porte parole du kremlin rappelle au
passage que les rassemblements des
derniers jours étaient non autorisés et
que les gens qui ont décidé d'y
participer malgré tout était conscient
des risques que cela implique
ces derniers jours nous avons fait face
à plusieurs reprises des appels directs
et indirects de participer à des actions
non autorisées et des mesures sont
prises pour que cela n'entraîne pas de
conséquence provocatrice ces mesures
sont efficaces ce qui permet vraiment
d'éviter les pires conséquences
la condamnation d' alexeï navalni mais
aussi les arrestations lors d'un
rassemblement en soutien à l'opposant
russe seront au coeur du déplacement à
moscou du chef de la diplomatie
européenne prévue vendredi le
gouvernement allemand a d'ailleurs fait
savoir que de nouvelles sanctions
européennes contre la russie ne sont pas
exclues toujours dans le cadre de cette
affaire navalni